greetings planet Houston I am General
Zod and may I wish you all a merry
zodmas let us talk about a character
that I have heard much about Santa Claus
I have heard much about this mystical
one that you call Klaus he does not
impress me
in fact I pity him he needs a reindeer
and the sleigh to fly I fly all natural
knows I could use a lift occasionally
where does he get these reindeer anyway
are they powered also by almighty yellow
Sun if so how do they fly at night I
will steal this reindeer technology and
make it my own
soon all of them will have fashionable
goatees and slick the antlers back their
coats would be made out of pure jet
black not unlike a pack of 12 tiny
stealth bombers flying through the night
but let's just talk more about this
Center fellow what gives him the right
to judge planet Houston's children
that's my job and what a pathetic
punishment to provide little children
coal that provides meat and what my
partner awesome fool to even extend it
to the children of Krypton she had a
better way to deal with petulant
children she would stuff their stockings
with kryptonite which will make them
weak I think them susceptible to
suggestion like stealing the mommy and
daddy's wallets and purses and giving
them to Elsa but don't worry it was all
going to a good cause it's giving off
the top to pay for that florid hairstyle
but getting back to the closet had why
do you houstonians find such comfort in
this horrible little winter pervert he
is a predator if you saw some fat rotund
German stocking your children all year
break into your house uninvited eat your
food and then show small plastic choking
hazard in your clothes what would you do
call the police or Dateline's To Catch a
Predator or at the very least declare
war on Germany what's that he lives in
the North Pole well that's easy a
military conflicts of the North Pole
would not be difficult define I have a
suspicion this person apparently lives
in the Arctic can fly where's red and
spends most of his life helping people
clearly this is the son of giraffe but
the very least some giant flying crimson
mutant polar bear in the way he should
be brought down true
and if he is a polar bear I shall skin
him and wear him if it's the son of
jor-el I shall skin him and wear him
final summer Santa Claus has no place in
the cydonia people's republic of houston
know his freaky munchkin army so just to
reiterate you better watch out you
better not cry you better not pout I'm
telling you why